okay I have a story to tell that I sort
of need to explain some background to
you about it's fascinating but the
entire thing might not be on anybody's
radar a ton of people have been tweeting
to me asking me to comment a reminder
gamergate is this incident that sort of
happened on the internet uh I covered it
from late 2014 to earlier mid-2015 it
was a involving the video game world
there was one side which said gamergate
is a movement which harasses women
online others said gamergate is a
movement which seeks to increase
journalistic standards for ethical video
game journalism we did a bunch of
interviews about this and it has now
been revealed that some of those
involved were actively doing opposition
research on a whole bunch of people
involved most of whom I'd whose names I
don't recognize but I was someone that
had an opposition research file created
a sort of dossier uh this is called the
crash override network which is an
organization founded by zoe quinn in the
wake of gamergate and some of the
group's activities were recently leaked
through some chat logs and one of the
activities that the group was involved
in was the building of these sort of
opposition research files on different
people that were commenting on or in any
way involved with reporting on gamergate
me being one of those people now I was
read it to call me even secondary I
don't even know that I was tertiary in
this entire gamergate thing so it's sort
of weird that there would even be an
opposition research file about me but we
now have that and it's been revealed
that there was a Trello board where
these dossiers were compiled on on
different people that were involved the
board was initially I guess ostensibly
put together to document harassment but
it now turns out that they were building
these opposition research files and I'm
gonna show you the dossier on me this is
the file on David Pakman which I will
put up on the screen for you here and as
you can see they had very very little on
me saying this was created by someone
going by the name Peter coffin I'm
apparently the 85th individual in this
dossier it was created on februari
9th of 2015 very very late at night
nearly two in the morning and it says
before he was a name searching it
gamergate neutral read pro gamer gate
completely untrue I me could not be more
untrue you journalists Pakman was an ink
cartridge recycling guru with a link to
a YouTube video out which is me talking
about ink cartridge recycling okay so
what is this all about right what does
this mean what they found on me the dirt
that was found on David Pakman at the
time was that seven years ago I worked
with an ink cartridge company called
castle inc which was actually an
advertiser on the show for a few weeks
and i did a video for them where I was
sort of the talent and I said hey should
really recycle ink cartridges blah blah
blah so when I saw this Rachel I wasn't
sure should I be thrilled that the worst
thing they found on me is that I was
involved in the recycling of ink
cartridges or should I be sort of
disturbed that all of the other things I
mean I've told far worse stories on the
show like the time I was arrested when I
was four months shy of age 21 for
holding a beer at a party I told the
story of when I was stopped by the
school police officer when I did not yet
have my license in northampton
massachusetts and thought hey i'll just
drive to school today nobody will know
I've told way worse stories on the show
I don't know if I should be thrilled
that the worst thing they found is the
ink cartridge thing or confuse that they
didn't just look at my own youtube
channel for the things that I've
admitted which are actually far worse I
think that it just kind of shows some
people can be very lazy when looking
into people's criminal histories I think
that also sometimes people can be lazy
in general when doing research like and
we saw your misidentification right
identified as a a dead gay teenager and
also as a former neo-nazi of course
right both accurate so clearly people
are just are doing great research here
so my reaction is I don't know why
anybody wasted time on me I was at best
tertiary in this entire gamergate thing
and that that's really my surprise am I
upset that it was revealed that I was
involved in this ink cartridge video no
the video continues to be available on
YouTube
i I'm not at all disturbed by that that
is the only comment I really have to
make today gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
TDPS the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s